I’m certain my wife would not agree that
I have good listening skills.
It’s human nature: you get preoccupied with
your own thoughts, and when I’m busy thinking
about something I don’t hear very well,
because my brain is sort of already engaged
and I don’t necessarily turn noise into
a cogent-enough thought that it gets in and
I actually acknowledge what somebody is saying—so
I’m just as guilty as anyone of not being
a good listener.
I think in order to overcome that you have
to deliberately listen, and not just to the
words, not just the text, but what was the
reason behind the text?
What do those words mean culturally?
How did the person say them and why?
Why did they say them now?
What’s the sense of urgency?
What is the actual message they’re trying
to get across?
And so, of course, the best way to verify
all that is to engage in discussion.
Repeat back what you think you heard.
A really clinical example is where Mission
Control is calling up something important
to the spaceship and we know that communication
is lousy—there’s little tiny speakers
and it’s radios and it’s clipped and it’s
digitized, and so we can’t just count on
everybody immediately understanding and having
good listening skills.
So we have like, “Houston, station.”
“Station, Houston, I’m listening.”
“Okay Houston what I wanted to talk to you
about was—whatever—the carbon dioxide
removal equipment, and there’s a problem
with the CDRA today and I’m in the checklist
on page 221 part B, let me know when you’re
there.”
“Okay.
All right.
I’m open to that page now.
Go ahead.”
So think about how that communication is happening.
You’ve gotten their attention, they’ve
told you “okay you have my attention”
and “now this is the thing I’m talking
about are you on the same page as me?”
“Yes.
I am on the same page as you.”
“Okay.
Now that both of us are on the same page now
let’s actually discuss why we’re trying
to accomplish this thing.
What are the details?
What do we need to know?
What do you know that I don’t know?”
And then come to a mutual conclusion of “Okay
this is what I’m going to do.”
“Yep I agree that’s what you’re going
to do.”
It’s so incredibly formalized: we’re talking
with the ground, but it’s a microcosm of
a regular conversation between any two people,
we just maybe aren’t quite as rigorous about
it.
But I think you should keep that in mind,
if you’re trying to be a good listener,
picture how the ground listens to a spaceship
and try and be that person.
Truly give them your attention.
Try and get on the same page.
Question, have a conversation.
Make sure you understand the intent.
Repeat it back.
And then get your actions verified after you
do them.
And if you can manage to do all those things,
even quickly, then I think you have the best
chance of being a good communicator—and
more importantly, a good listener.